I don't sort of preconceive my career I
just kind of take and grab what
interests me I do like to be diverse I'm
an actor I love to act so when I read a
script and I and I see the range in the
arc of the character that gets me
excited so I think an actor should a not
worry about genre not worry about any
sort of you know you know trying to hit
a mark or you know trying to be somebody
other than themselves
well the goal of acting is to make it
personal everything is personal so you
have to now if you're not like your
character you have to find that slice of
you or that part of you that is and then
you have to dwell and focus on that part
of it at the exclusion of everything
else you cannot become somebody else but
what you can do is highlight the
qualities that are similar to your
character so it's all about
personalization and then you just have
to live eat sleep and drink with your
character you know to to inhabit him
that's all there is to it and whatever
that takes to do that's what you have to
do I'm looking for as Jack Nicholson
says behavior that's all he's interested
in he wants to do the little things you
know I can't I can show you how I feel I
can but I can best tell you the story
through my physical actions so any
little piece of that that's usually what
I'm concentrating on in this movie
believe for this I play a trainer if I'm
playing a chef if I'm playing a pilot I
just have to get to know how they move
as you know because everything is
specific to their job so as a trainer
you know I just got to I hung out with
trainers Freddie Roach took me through
his his training camp with Manny
Pacquiao and Bradley I spent so much
time with them and watching and
researching and soaking in listening 24
hours a day to the voice looking at the
the body movement gaining weight for it
anything that you can do to get you into
that character and then don't get out of
character stay there that's what excites
me I have to say all the other stuff is
is business and
so good about it but when I acting that
communication having energy between me
and the circumstances the other actors
that is the most exhilarating thing
about acting and having true real
moments that are pure because they're
few and far between and that's what all
the research is done I I try to do I I
know going into the first day of film I
know that script backwards and forwards
not my part just everybody's part and
then so when I get on set then I can
just let it all go and be free
it's no good getting to know me Aaron
because that's not going to help the
film for example if I'm if I'm working
with a child and I'm playing his father
then from the second I meet him I am my
character I don't tell him that but for
example if we have a good relationship
I'll play games with them I'll all
asking personal questions I'll get I'll
be in their space at all times if it's a
woman a love interest I do the same
thing with that you know I mean
obviously not crossing the lines but if
I'm a villain and this guy has to hate
me I'll make him hate me I'll play a
little games with them you know I just
feel like the little moments that the
audience is looking for if you want
those moments and you want real natural
energy it really behooves you to to play
these sort of psychological games with
people you have to make a director your
best friend and there's in this notion
in acting that you can only do this
scene one way well I don't believe in
that I believe that if you are prepared
to give your direct director a range of
different interpretations of the same
scene the same line the same word and
still feel that you're being integral to
yourself and your process then you will
better manage yourself on set and
throughout your career give them
everything don't worry about what he's
going to use
and all this sort of I mean within
limits but you don't want you want to be
able to give yourself the best
opportunity and best experience on set
so if you're only prepared to do it one
way you're probably going to find get
resistance from the director if you can
say to the director yeah I can do it
this way but I can also do it this way
in this way in this way he's going to
love you
and he's going to give you more
opportunity
[Music]